[Música]
i
por primera vez un ex presidente ha sido
sentenciado de un delito en ecuador' una
sentencia que significa un duro revés
para la vida política de rafael correa
que lo inhabilita de por vida a
postularse a cualquier cargo de elección
popular inclusive luego de concluída la
sentencia de ocho años en su contra
rafael correa tiene un largo camino
judicial en ecuador que suman 34
investigaciones penales que se
encuentran en fase inicial por supuestos
delitos de peculado y tráfico de
influencias una sentencia que no ha
estado exenta de cuestionamientos o
celebraciones según los involucrados por
responder más a intereses políticos
electorales e intereses judiciales
sumando las penas en los 11 casos de
peculado y cohecho pendientes que son
los que se pueden juzgar en su ausencia
las penas podrían oscilar entre 51 y 137
años según las sentencias establecidas
por esos delitos un ecuador rafael
correa tampoco podrá participar como
candidato a la vicepresidencia en las
elecciones del año 2021 quien destacó
que no le interesa su futuro político
pero aseguró que trabajará por apoyar a
su sustituto en las próximas elecciones
generales
[Música]
en méxico continúan los reveses a
expresidentes de la república ahora tocó
el turno a felipe calderón pues el
instituto nacional electoral determinó
negar el registro como partido político
a la agrupación mexico libre que
encabezan él y su esposa margarita
zavala el argumento fue que un
porcentaje de las aportaciones recibidas
no está claro de dónde provienen es
decir no está identificado el origen de
ciertas donaciones en respuesta calderón
arremetió contra los consejeros
electorales dijo que sus argumentos son
falsos y que acudirá ante el tribunal
electoral del poder judicial
el actual presidente andrés manuel lópez
obrador le recomendó a calderón que haga
lo que él y su movimiento hicieron en
2006 cuando dijo calderón les robó la
presidencia es decir que encabece un
movimiento de protesta pacífico le
sugirió también que acuda con sus amigos
de la oea pero eso sí le dijo entre
risas que no vaya a nueva york- pues ahí
se encuentra preso genaro garcía luna su
ex secretario de seguridad
[Música]
bolivia vive un proceso electoral
diferente primero por la pandemia y
segundo porque el ex presidente evo
morales por primera vez en 31 años no
podrá postular a un cargo público eso
debido a que ha recibido un revés de la
justicia paceña y también del tribunal
supremo electoral que han inhabilitado
su candidatura a primer senador por
cochabamba por su partido el movimiento
al socialismo morales empezó su carrera
política hace 31 años les decía
postulando como diputado sin embargo las
primeras ocasiones no ha ganado ese
curul pero si lo ha hecho desde hace 23
años cuando se ha convertido en diputado
nacional y luego desde el año 2006 ha
sido presidente del estado ha gobernado
bolivia durante más de 13 años y por eso
les decía que ahora será una elección
atípica el más su partido ha decidido
acatar el fallo de la justicia para
garantizar el proceso electoral y ya
está buscando al reemplazante de morales
para candidato a primer senador por
cochabamba
[Música]